Schlaf wird uns in die Wiege gelegt.
Er ist lebensnotwendig.
Und wenn du wissen willst,
warum das so ist,
dann bist du genau hier richtig.
Ich bin Thea Herold
und arbeite seit zehn Jahren
im Team der Schlafakademie Berlin.
Wir haben diese
präventive Plattform gegründet,
um moderne Kenntnisse
über den gesunden Schlaf zu vermitteln,
und das Vertrauen
in den eigenen Schlaf zu verstärken.
In unserem ersten Video geht es darum,
warum die Natur den Schlaf erfand,
was die Aufgaben des Schlafens sind,
und warum diese Zeit
keine Zeitverschwendung ist,
sondern lebensnotwendig
und uns deswegen
auch durch das ganze Leben begleitet.
In unserem zweiten Video,
das in ein paar Tagen
online gestellt wird,
werden wir über Schlaftipps sprechen.
Das heißt, wir beraten dich,
was zu tun ist,
um den gesunden Schlaf zu festigen,
und dein Vertrauen
in den Schlaf wieder zu stärken.
Aktiviere am besten die Glocke,
um das nicht zu verpassen.
Schlaf ist ein ganz besonderer Zustand.
Er ist bis heute auch noch ein Mysterium.
Zu einem gewissen Teil.
Wir wissen allerdings, dass wir jeden Tag
ein Mal in den Schlaf fallen müssen.
Wachsein und Schlafen wechseln sich ab.
Nun leben wir im 21. Jahrhundert,
das heißt, um uns herum
gibt es immer einen Zeitgeist von 24/7,
der sogenannten "Immer-Wach-Gesellschaft".
In diesem Rhythmus leben wir aber nicht.
Nach wie vor sind wir biologisch
an die zirkadiane Rhythmik gebunden.
Und nach wachen Stunden,
geschützt von Dunkelheit und Stille,
schlafen wir ein,
einmal am Tag.
Seitdem der Schlaf vermessen wurde,
lernen wir, ihn immer besser zu verstehen.
Wir haben erfahren,
die Prozesse im Schlafen
sind sehr komplex und überaus dynamisch.
Es gibt unterschiedliche Schlafphasen.
Sie wechseln sich ab,
und wiederholen sich mehrmals.
In der Einschlafphase
beginnen wir uns zu entspannen.
Die Herzfrequenz sinkt,
der Atem wird ruhiger,
die Sinne kehren sich nach innen,
und wir entspannen uns.
Auch der Blutdruck geht nach unten.
Im Leichtschlaf entspannen wir uns weiter.
Der mitteltiefe Schlaf,
in dem wir als Erwachsene ungefähr
die Hälfte der Schlafzeit verbringen,
bedeutet, dass wir uns weiter entspannen
und dass er auch
ab und zu unterbrochen wird,
ganz natürlich durch die Arousal.
Das sind kleine Wachepisoden,
die uns die Natur
ins Programm des Schlafes hineinschreibt.
Der Tiefschlaf wiederum
ist der effektivste
unter den erholsamen Schlafphasen.
Die besondere Phase ist der Traumschlaf.
In dieser Schlafphase träumen wir.
Wir agieren nicht in der Traumschlafphase,
denn der Muskeltonus
ist fast gegen Null heruntergesunken.
So agieren wir nicht aus,
was unsere Träume bewirken.
Aber es gibt eine Ausnahme,
die Augenbewegungen.
Die sind sehr schnell,
von links nach rechts,
unter den geschlossenen Augen,
weshalb der Traumschlaf
auch rapid eye movement heißt.
Schlafen ist also ein Prozess,
der körperlichen und geistigen Erholung,
das ist bekannt.
Aber ist uns auch bekannt und bewusst,
jeder schläft seinen eigenen Schlaf?
Der Schlaf ist also ein Prozess,
der unlösbar an deine eigenen
individuellen Eigenschaften gebunden ist.
Verschiedene Prozesse
bestimmen ihn, beeinflussen ihn.
Unter anderem der Schlafdruck,
aber auch der Chronotyp,
also deine ganz individuelle Ausprägung,
wie du schlafen
und wachen in ihrer Regulation erlebst.
Den Chronotypen
haben wir unser ganzes Leben,
aber er wird vor allen Dingen
in der Pubertät ausgeprägt.
Danach ist er mehr oder minder
als erwachsener Chronotyp festgelegt.
Es gibt drei Hauptgruppen,
den Morgentypen, das sind die Lerchen,
den neutralen Typen, das sind die Tauben
und den Spättypen,
die Eulen, den Abendtyp.
Während wir erwachsen werden,
entwickeln wir unsere Persönlichkeit,
sozusagen unsere wache Persönlichkeit.
Aber genauso entwickeln wir auch
unsere Besonderheiten im Schlafen.
Also wenn man so will,
die Schlafpersönlichkeit.
Bei der Schlafpersönlichkeit ist es so,
dass viele Faktoren zusammenspielen,
zum Beispiel
die sogenannte Wohlfühlschlaflänge.
Das ist die Zeit,
die jeder von uns am liebsten,
vom Anteil des 24-stündigen Tages,
im Schlafen verbringt.
Es gibt die langen Schläfer.
Die größte Gruppe
sind die normallangen Schläfer,
die zwischen sieben
und acht Stunden Schlaf brauchen.
Und tatsächlich
gibt es auch geborene Kurzschläfer.
Zusammengefasst muss man sagen,
wir unterscheiden uns also,
ob wir die frühen Typen sind,
die normalen Typen sind,
oder späte Typen sind.
Wann sind wir am liebsten wach?
Im Beschreibungstext
findest du einen Link,
der dir hilft
deinen Chronotypen zu bestimmen.
Probiere es aus
und schreib mir doch mal in die Kommentare
welcher Chronotyp du bist.
Wir wissen es noch nicht ganz genau,
weshalb der Schlaf
von der Natur erfunden wurde.
Hier sind fünf Gründe,
warum wir schlafen:
Ein Drittel unseres Lebens
verbringen wir im Schlaf,
aber es ist lebensnotwendig.
Und schlafen ist keine Zeitverschwendung.
Der zweite Grund:
Unser Körper wird im Schlaf
körperlich, mental
und geistig regeneriert.
Wir brauchen
diese Erholungsphase Tag für Tag.
Wir nehmen auch Kreativität
und Inspiration in den Schlafstunden auf.
Wir werden sozusagen bereit gemacht,
dem nächsten Tag,
mit all seinen Herausforderungen,
ausgeschlafen zu begegnen.
Wichtig:
Wir können unseren Schlaf nicht speichern.
Wir können also nichts machen,
um auf Vorrat zu schlafen.
Weshalb wir das also
in der Schlaf-Wach-Regulation
einmal am Tag tun.
Dritter Grund:
Wir lernen im Schlaf.
Was heißt das?
Wir verarbeiten im Schlaf alle Eindrücke.
Alles, was wir gelernt haben am Vortag,
sortieren es in unser Gedächtnis ein
und bereiten uns aber gleichzeitig
auch auf Lösungen vor,
die für den nächsten Tag
vielleicht gebraucht werden.
Es ist buchstäblich wahr,
wir sind am Morgen klüger,
als am Abend.
Vierter Grund:
Schlafzeit ist Heilzeit.
Oder man könnte auch sagen:
Da wird repariert.
Unsere Immunkraft
ist während der Nacht am höchsten.
Unsere Verletzungen und Wunden
heilen in der Nacht am besten.
Schlaf dich gesund,
ist also nicht nur ein Sprichwort,
sondern wortwörtlich Realität,
das passiert jede Nacht.
Unser Immunsystem
arbeitet nächtens mit Hochdruck.
Wir haben Reparaturarbeiten,
die während des Tages erforderlich werden,
in der Nacht am besten zu lösen.
Dann sind wir am stärksten
in unserer Immunkraft.
Und der fünfte Grund:
Unser Schlaf hilft uns,
gut durch das Leben zu kommen.
Er altert mit uns,
aber er bremst auch die Alterungsprozesse,
wenn er gut ist.
Wenn du einen Durchhänger hast,
probiere es doch mal
mit einem Mittagsschlaf,
mit einem Nickerchen,
ganz ohne schlechtes Gewissen.
Das Tagesschläfchen
sollte um die 15 Minuten dauern.
Stell dir einfach einen Timer,
setze dich gemütlich hin,
aber auch vielleicht im Liegen,
einfach die Augen schließen,
und für einen kurzen Moment
entspannt einschlafen.
In Tokio ist diese Gewohnheit
seit Generationen üblich.
Sie nennen es Inemuri
und sind damit richtige Meister geworden.
Wenn du also noch mehr erfahren möchtest,
wie du für deinen gesunden Schlaf
etwas tun kannst,
dann schau in unser zweites Video,
das in wenigen Tagen online gehen wird.
Da lernst du,
wie du Schlafstörer erkennst
und bekommst Ermutigungen
aus der modernen Schlafhygiene,
wie es dir gelingt,
für deinen Schlaf etwas Gutes zu tun.
Hier auf dem AOK Gesundheitskanal
findest du viele Videos
rund um die Gesundheitsthemen
Bewegung, Ernährung
und viele andere interessante Themen.
Abonniere einfach
den AOK Gesundheitskanal,
um keine Videos zu verpassen.